Oh
hi I'm Matt Welch for reason TV I'm here
in Las Vegas at Freedom Fest joined the
day by John Goodman the author priceless
thanks for joining us John Lana be with
you curing the healthcare crisis let's
get to like first definitions here what
is our healthcare crisis right now as
you define it well the problem is we
have so completely suppressed the
marketplace in health care that none of
us ever sees a real price for anything
no patient no doctor no employer no
employee and because of that we're all
facing perverse incentives and when we
act on those perverse incentives we make
costs higher quality lower access more
difficult and we create all of the
problems that we're having what's an
example of the quality being lowered
just to throw another well on the
provider side the incentives for doctors
hospital administrators and others is to
maximize against reimbursement formulas
to get as much money as you can out of
the payment formulas of Medicare
Medicaid Blue Cross and lawyer plans and
so when the providers are doing that
they're not putting us first they're
putting that payment formula first and
when they do that they're not providing
us with optimal care so let's go through
some of the solutions what are these
market-oriented solutions what could
they do how can be do we need to empower
patients we need to free doctors
basically liberate the marketplace so
that patients and doctors are free to
solve their own problems right now
they're not how does that happen what
what are the mechanics of freeing them
up you need a liberal health savings
account they can wrap around any
third-party payment plan so that people
can manage more of their own health care
dollars basically all preventive care
all diagnostic tests ought to be paid
for by patients from their own health
savings account but even the chronically
ill can manage a lot of their own money
and they can do so very successfully and
we ought to allow them to do it are we
thinking about health care wrong as
there's some fundamental mistake of the
way that most Americans are most
policymakers think about health care as
a policy question both on the right and
the left there's one huge mistake
everybody is making and that is the
thighs but the way you make health care
accessible is you make it free at the
point of delivery when we do that we
forget that if people don't pay with
money they'll pay with something else
i'm primarily they're paying with time
but those non-price barriers to care are
more important in deterring access than
the fee the doctor charges you look
around the world it's not a monolithic
system out there for the provision of
health care what is a country or system
that is doing interesting things that
you might learn South Africa is an
interesting country in the private
marketplace more than half the account
of the insurance there is health savings
account insurance so they have a much
more liberal use of health savings
accounts and patients controlling their
own dollars Singapore is sort of
interesting it's had a medisave account
which is their version of a health
savings account since 1984 and then
switzerland is one of the few about the
only other developed country that has
mainly private system they mandate
private insurance but people own their
own insurance is portable travels with
them from job a job so you can find
interesting things going on but you're
not going to find a real market in any
of these countries how important is it
to break the link between
your employer and your health insurance
I don't know that that's all that
important but I think portable insurance
is really important so your employer
ought to be able to pay premiums for
insurance that you own and you could
take with you when you leave the job in
the wake of now the Obamacare ruling and
that's when your book came out so
congratulations on all that how
important is it in your scheme that
Obamacare get repealed or do you think
that's actually a possibility regardless
of the windows well Obamacare either
needs to be repealed or it needs to be
hugely altered one way or the other we
need to move from this top-down
regulatory approach to healthcare to one
that liberates doctors patients and
other people in the system that's great
well thank you very much for joining us
John Goodman the again the name of the
book is priceless during the health care
crisis for recent TV I mountains
you